well russian president vladimir putin
has slammed the west saying the days of
a unipolar world led by the united
states were over
in a speech full of grievances at the
saint petersburg international economic
forum putin said what he called the
west's economic blitzkrieg of sanctions
had failed he also played down ukraine's
possible eu entry saying he had nothing
against it unlike the security risk of
kiev joining nato that he alleged when
he started the invasion putin accused
the u.s of acting as a colonial force
and said tectonic changes in the global
order would see states like russia come
to the fore
the era of a unipolar world order is
over despite all the attempts to
preserve it by any means
these changes are a natural process
because it's difficult to combine the
civilizational variety of the planet and
the wealth of cultures with political
economic and other cliches
the cliches don't work here the cliches
that bluntly without any alternatives
are being imposed from one center
let's bring in dw russia analyst
constantine eggert who joins us from the
lithuanian capital vilnius constantine
good to see you so a determined russian
president vladimir putin speaking there
did he room did he remain optimistic and
defiant throughout
yes absolutely and um i think that uh
what the main at least my main takeaway
from uh
this speech very long speech by the way
is that putin really believes that
economic sanctions imposed by the west
uh on on russia will not work because
others will come to bail it out i think
that he is convinced that a his
financial team is good enough to uh
stave off financial catastrophe and be
that uh there's going to be enough
investors let's say from asia uh that uh
will come and bail out russian economy
and by the way uh speaking about the
speech if i may uh it was very
interesting how he repeatedly used this
kind of traditional left-wing um
post-colonial discourse from western
academia to rule the audience where
there were a lot of people from china
india basically from asia and africa are
trying to basically please them with
this kind of entire western pitch
constantine we'll we'll speak in a
moment the international uh community
has condemned russia's invasion of
ukraine time and time again german
chancellor olaf schultz said on friday
that it's absolutely necessary for
leaders to speak directly with the
russian president to end the war so
let's take a listen what chancellor
schultz had to say
it is absolutely necessary to speak to
putin and i will continue to do so as
the french president will also
and there
are some
countries needed and some leaders needed
that speak to him and it is necessary
that they are clear
because when i speak to putin i say
for instance the same things i said to
you
please understand that there will be no
dictate peace and if you really believe
that you will rob some land and then
hope that the times will change and all
the things be will become normal again
this is the mistake
right so chancellor charles believes
that dialogue is essential with
president putin but is there actually
any indication that he's open to
listening or compromising with the west
constantine
well
over nearly four months now there is no
sign that putin actually shifted in his
position actually i think that he uses
these uh phone calls with the president
macron and chancellor schultz uh to tell
the russian public look we are still
respected we're doing everything right
might is right especially i think in
russia this this particular message uh
sounds quite powerful and uh dialogue is
important
no doubt about that the issue is the
the basically what is the dialogue about
and i think that this is something that
so far
has been missing from this discourse of
the necessity of dialogue with putin
because putin seems to use it just for
propaganda purposes
dw russia analyst constantine eggert
thank you
thank you
for an analysis of putin's remarks let's
bring in timothy ash
emerging market strategist at blue bay
asset management thanks for joining us
now putin said today that russia's
financial systems uh and markets have
stabilized and that a crisis has failed
to materialize would you say this is
accurate
well they crashed initially uh you know
huge drops in equity and bond prices uh
well actually bond prices have stayed
very low they were about a 130 cents for
the russian long bond and they trade
about 20 cents now so that's not true
the ruble has stabilized but it's a
pretty artificial exchange rate at the
moment because it's a very illiquid
market imports have collapsed and
obviously energy prices are higher so
that's helping them but you know
sanctions are not meant to uh well it's
very difficult to stop the russian
economy uh straight away sanctions will
have an impact over the very long term
uh undoubtedly they make the outlook for
the russian economy pretty bleak low
growth low investments difficult to
access financing and and stagnation i
think is is going to be the story for
russia over the next decade
right i mean putin made it seem like
everything is quite fine in russia right
now but he also alluded to the fact that
uh regular russians might have to cope
with some challenges what do you think
he could be anticipating there and do
you think the russian people
are ready to deal with that
well he's right i mean you know uh being
isolated from uh international markets
and the international economy remember
there's a lot of focus on on the energy
embargo and whether or not europe will
impose a full energy embargo this year
but whatever happens uh whether the
timing of that embargo what is pretty
clear is russia is now deemed to be an
unreliable energy partner and europe
will absolutely diversify away from
russia over the medium to long term and
that will cut you know billions hundreds
of billions of dollars of revenues for
russia over the long term so russians
are going to be a lot poorer uh maybe
they haven't realized that yet their you
know their their ability travel uh has
been significantly restricted um jobs
are going to be lost as i said growth is
going to be pretty mediocre uh capital
will leave the country and and uh i
think there'll be a big brain drain out
of russia uh over the medium to longer
term as well
timothy ash thank you for putting that
in context
my pleasure